now I am become
farmer embodiment of tech
meme so I went and bought a ranch of
sorts it's not totally off- grid but
it's got one foot out the door the first
step to surviving off-grid for a
terminally online person such as myself
is to immediately reestablish a
connection back to the grid
unfortunately there are really no great
options for internet out here there's
not even like the 5G cellular stuff so
the only choice is to essentially launch
satellites up into space and in orbit
and use them for internet which is of
course starlink with starlink you need
to find a good spot to mount the dish
itself and then the modem is going to
need to be within 75 ft or 23 M from
that point you can also pay Starling
some extra money uh for a longer cable
to be up to 150 ft or 46 M instead but
that's it the problem is is at the ranch
there are multiple buildings 100 to 300
M apart or more and most importantly the
area that I've made into my office is
pretty significantly surrounded by trees
and it just wouldn't be a good spot for
the starlink dish I'm still trying some
different spots but for right now I have
the dish mounted on a detached garage I
would also note that this is absolutely
not the correct way to mount the
ridgemount kit I'm aware thank you for
the comments below um it's probably
going to be moved to a completely
different building entirely I just kind
of wanted to test this location and then
test another location I do actually have
it attached with some screws into that
metal roof and actually a day after I
put this up we had some pretty brutal
wind storms it was when those like
winter Arctic storms were blowing across
the United States and at least here down
south it did get a little cold but
mostly we got just insane wind so I
thought surely this was going to
completely dismantle my internet uh but
nope this actually held really strong so
anyway still I do think I eventually
want to get this up on the barn roof
instead of this roof here it's an easier
roof for me to climb it's also a safer
roof to climb and uh the fall would
actually be better should things not go
so well so so I'm just waiting for the
summer months or at least a warmer day
so that grip is just a little bit better
on that roof metal roofs are really cool
and all but they're built literally for
stuff to slide off of them so that would
include the human climbing it also
trying to carry like a dish and an
impact
driver and all of that um I did also try
to reach out to DJI to get them to send
me one of those drones that can carry up
to 40 kg that's basically a crane in
drone form which is really cool but uh
you know for some reason they did not
get back to me uh I'm sure they were
just uh really busy uh anyway with
multiple buildings and mount location
ations the logistics of networking even
once you have the dish up can become a
bit complex in the past I've been able
to make do with these like Google Wi-Fi
Now Nest units and eventually I did set
up a small Wi-Fi Bridge with tplink
access points which went something like
12 M or something like that and that
actually worked really well uh with some
further research and help from Daniel
kiawa the co-author of the neural
networks from scratch book and ns. I
settled on few ubiquity units as options
to help me out here I did also reach out
to ubiquity but I didn't hear back from
them um I know enough about like Wi-Fi
and networking and stuff to know that I
know very little so I'm probably going
to say and and do things that are stupid
I apologize feel free to correct me in
the comment section below as I know many
of you will uh without uh prompting so
the main problem at hand is you might
think well why don't you just run a
physical line well at 100 to 300 M this
really isn't acceptable for something
like a a like a cad8 cable or something
like that a typical ethernet cable wants
a maximum distance of about 30 m before
the signal starts to degrade this is
also most likely why you can't get a
cable any longer than 150 ft from like
Star length you're probably already
seeing slight degradation there
theoretically you could continue going
further you just need another switch or
like a repeater or something along the
way but doing this would require not
only that switch but now you have to
power that switch um and and that's the
problem is there is no power along the
way if there was power along the way
well guess what I'm going to plug in
just a bunch of uh mesh units or
something like that so you could also do
maybe your own fiber optic cabling I
wouldn't even know where to begin there
though so I'm just not even including
that so then there are things like Wi-Fi
extenders I've not personally found
success ever with one of these despite
how hard I've tried but I also am going
to going to be honest I have not bought
such a product like a Wi-Fi extender
product in probably like a decade
because they just seem like total junk
to me every time um I haven't heard of a
good one so if you know of a good Wi-Fi
extender like truly in in its true form
where it extends your Wi-Fi doesn't
create a new network anything like that
uh for sure let me know but then there's
mesh Wi-Fi I've historically used these
Google Wi-Fi units now Nest uh but I've
found mesh Wi-Fi to be quite phenomenal
even for something like your entire
house but also if even if you have like
a property that's like maybe like a 1
acre or less uh usually the Google Wi-Fi
units can reach like the entire property
if if you have enough also super
surprisingly even at about 100 m I was
able to pick up my Google Wi-Fi unit
through two walls and through a bunch of
trees uh using those Wi-Fi antennas that
uh sometimes come with your motherboard
I've always thought these were like just
total gimmicks but they actually
actually worked shockingly well at this
distance I the only reason I had them
plugged in is because I use a Bluetooth
uh Mouse and I found that if I didn't
have it plugged in the mouse was a
little spotty and sporadic but with them
plugged in it worked really well but my
in my head I'm thinking these are good
for like a room I had no idea that they
would reach as far as they would nor did
I know that like I I still thought like
for transmitting let's say if you're
trying to get like a Wi-Fi signal you
still have to have a you could have a
powerful receiver but you also need a
powerful transmitter if you want the the
handshake to go well but anyway like I
said I know enough to know I don't know
enough so anyways that's the problem
with this too is that it was also only
my main PC that was able to get some
sort of internet signal this way and
also it was a little spotty and sporadic
the starlink service itself is providing
me with about a 100 megabits per second
down sometimes I get way more than that
sometimes I get way less than that it's
just kind of depends randomly it seems
um and then I only get about 10ish up
with the Google Wi-Fi units let's say
from where it's mounted through those
two walls and through the trees and all
that um with just a typical Wi-Fi device
like my phone or something like that I
was getting maybe like 2 to four
megabits per second down um and like
pennies up and then on my main computer
I was able to get about 30 and three
something like that but it was just not
a super reliable connection and it would
drop periodically and then if I wanted
to do something like a video call or
something like that it just was not
still not quite acceptable um throughout
this video I'm going to reference Google
uh speed tests uh to do those
measurements that's how I'm calculating
100 megabits or 30 or three I don't
actually know if this is an appropriate
way to measure signal strength or
quality or anything like that um my
guess is that it's either you know
you're losing signal strength but are at
the point of reception of the signal uh
is it am I getting 100 megabits per
second or maybe better put like if I'm
getting 30 for example am I getting 30
megabits per second or am I getting
bursts of 100 megabits per second and
it's just averaging out to 30 or three
or or whatever it happens to be I don't
know I know enough to know I don't know
either way I wanted better than that 30
down I'm paying for 100 down I want 100
down um I also wanted slightly better
latency and I just I wanted a more
reliable connection okay getting back to
our question about connecting uh
multiple buildings we've we've covered
like mesh Wi-Fi we've covered uh Wi-Fi
extenders uh the next thing is you know
like with with with mesh Wi-Fi for
example this is kind of a
multi-directional sort of broadcast of
your internet um or your network and the
next thing is these Wi-Fi Bridges or
even like pointto point so what about a
more focused beam like Connection in one
exact Direction and this is where Wi-Fi
Bridges and pointto point come in now in
my little brain I hear Point too point I
hear Wi-Fi Bridge um that sure sounds
like exactly the same thing now
technologically under the hood they are
not the same thing um again I know
enough to know I don't know but uh my
understanding is a Wi-Fi Bridge connects
two separate networks together it just
Bridges two networks now again a bridge
in my opinion uh connects two separate
locations together so I would think
these are the same thing they are not so
a Wi-Fi Bridge connects two networks
together a point to
point uh I I I believe it would be fair
to say extend your network um it it is
the most close you can be to as if you
ran a physical line that's how I
understand it again correct me in the
comments as I'm sure some of you might
already be doing if I got that wrong um
the only other thing that I could sort
of find is like pointto Point might be
able to extend further but really
pointto point and a Wi-Fi Bridge from
what I can find um and what makes sense
is both of those can go kilometers or
miles however you want to measure it so
U they probably can both do whatever it
is you you want to do do so anyway armed
with the knowledge that I might want a
Wi-Fi bridge I might want a point to
point I settled on these ubiquity Nano
stations which can do both uh beyond
that I also got some Poe injectors since
the Nano stations require power over
ethernet at the starlink modem router I
don't actually have Poe I do have Poe
like in my office switches but I
actually kind of wanted a poe just like
right on the other side of that wall I
do have a switch I could use for that um
I just get very uh protective and and
rationing and uh I don't know I feel
like a little bit of a prepper when it
comes to certain bits of technology or
something like I never want to actually
use my Poe switches uh so if I have a
nice Poe switch and I know all I want to
do is power one thing I'm not going to
use that switch so so anyway I got these
Poe injectors as well um and mostly
because I basically want there to be a
short CA basically a cable that just
just goes through the wall uh because
the Nano stations are weatherproof and
stuff well rathera weather resistant I
would call them um that sits on the
outside of that wall that way you don't
have to shoot through a wall or a window
you can go through a window and my guess
is at the distance I'm trying to go I
probably could just go straight through
a window I don't I don't think it would
be a problem but um because I'm going
through a wall I actually want that wall
cable to be just like a short like 3-ft
cable or something like that um come
through the wall and then have a new
cable that is all the interior inside um
uh networking then I also got some
mounting hardware and some silicone to
seal the holes in the
walls each ubiquity unit is actually
pretty simple you just have the unit and
if you pop this cover here you can slide
in your ethernet cable which is both for
internet and power for the total setup
you start with your actual internet
source that's going to be this yellow
ethernet cable for me that's going to my
starlink router so internet is coming
from that frustratingly I also need to
buy an ethernet adapter for the starlink
modem SL router honestly it's it's
basically a crime to sell a router
without even a single ethernet port
honestly it should they should all come
with at least four um but not even one
that's a that's
criminal I believe this is just for gen
two units from starlink and gen one and
gen 3 both have one but this one does
not and whoever decided to ship a router
without an ethernet port deserves a
swift kick in so the internet source
yellow goes into the land slot on the
poe adapter injector and or just any
port on a Poe switch and then the red
cable is the actual Poe that will go uh
to that first ubiquity we'll call it the
transmitting unit I did get a little
sidetracked thinking I could remove the
bottom of the ubiquity unit because my
ethernet cables just have a lot of this
extra plastic around the Jack and it
made them harder to to plug in and
instead of just simply removing that
little bottom part I end up dismantling
the entire unit so now we can see the
inside of that unit um enjoy anyway
carrying on the red Poe goes into the
ubiquity unit and then that ubiquity
unit will theoretically beam the
internet to this next ubiquity unit
another Poe and then this time that's a
blue cable and then again a yellow
ethernet cable which is connected to the
Lan of the poe injector and then boom
there's your Bridge or point to point I
then decided it would be prudent to be
matchy matchy and make both Poe blue and
the Lan yellow um this matching should
provide an extra approximately 2
megabits per second speed and decreased
latency by at least a few milliseconds
so it's worth the effort now it was time
to power things up and set everything up
I understand this is not yet building to
building um I'm just purely trying to
see does the connection work is this as
easy as I hope it's going to be Etc I
definitely don't want to be debugging
things when they're when both units are
like 100 plus meters apart I downloaded
the app to my phone plugged in the first
unit set it as a bridge gave it a name
and the app autogenerated what looked to
be a decent enough password dynamically
it also appeared to me I could change
the IP if I so wanted but I just wanted
to see everything as default and see how
it all worked from there it took about
30 seconds for the unit to finish
initializing I then powered on the
second unit located again in the app set
it up the app just asked me if I wanted
to connect it to my other unit that it
must have detected was also running I
said yes and that was it it was
shockingly simple um I'm sure there are
way more advanced operations required
sometimes but this really is like 2
minutes of setup up and um I'm pretty
sure these units are set as Wi-Fi
Bridges there is an option and there's
various options in this app but I've
seen you can set it as point to point if
you wanted uh the other cool thing is
the app will actually tell you how well
your units are aligned to each other so
when you are finally setting them up at
a good distance it's pretty useful as
you're trying to figure out how how much
you want to rotate a unit um it's pretty
useful to to get that information of
like how well aligned are they
especially like at 100 m you can still
pretty well see it but imagine you're
trying to go for for like a mile or a
couple kilometers or something um you
Pro you wouldn't even be able to see it
you could have like I don't know finder
scope or something to try to see it but
that would be a lot harder so anyways
that's kind of cool so it looks like
everything is working and now it's
actually time to actually install these
units and poke some holes in some walls
hole poked then we send the ethernet
through using literally 200 IQ then
we'll Mount the ubiquity unit up on the
wall we do the same thing on the other
side and and boom we have a clear line
of sight that should give us a good
result to establish this line of sight I
did do a little bit of wilderness
conquering uh but not too bad I just had
to trim some branches I cut down a
couple of smaller trees uh just so that
when the wind blows I don't lose
Internet because a branch blows in there
or when the rain
rains it doesn't like weigh down a
branch or something and and block it so
sure enough after this change I get
about 100 plus down which is awesome the
upload still isn't epic but this is not
on starlink it's on ubiquity
as far as I can tell this truly is just
as good as my starlink connection which
is super cool that's exactly what I was
going for so at the moment internet
beams down via satellite to the dish on
top of that detached garage comes around
inside through that wall and into the
starlink router SL modem from there I
also do need that uh ethernet adapter
because and then from there that goes
into a switch one port on that switch
leads to some mesh units that then
Powers the uh networking and all that
Wi-Fi for the house and the other one is
leading back outside that wall to that
first ubiquity transmitting unit then
beams internet memes through the woods
here to the second ubiquity we'll call
it the receiving unit which feeds in
through that wall to that Poe injector
and then out of that Poe injector across
the floor up the walls around the doors
uh and then into the obviously server
room again around the floor and up into
that rack into one of the switches in
this case it's just the gigabit switch
because this is just my internet in I
don't really think I need more than
gigabit also uh the Nano stations can't
TR I think the Nano station best case
scenario is going to be gigabit so even
if I wanted to so for example we go from
this gigabit switch into the 10 gig
switch so so the 10 gig switch does
eventually get internet obviously but
then the you the things that are plugged
into that 10 gig switch are like my main
computer my NZ uh and then soon like the
Puget machine and potentially a couple
but again I like to ration things and
I'd rather have an open port than waste
the port so so the 10 gig switch is only
for the the the best of the best the
rest get the uh gigabit but even if I
wanted to access my NAS from let's say a
machine at the house for example the
best I could ever hope for is going to
be gigabit anyways because that's the
peak of the Nano stations so there's no
reason to try to network any faster than
that if I ever did try to have some of
the more fancy ubiquity units that would
be kind of interesting to uh potentially
have 10 gig all over the place over
Wi-Fi would be pretty cool still quite a
bit quite still quite a bit more
machines to set up and network here but
things are definitely starting to
finally come together for the astute
among you yes that is right the power
for that pdu is indeed coming from the
dryer hookup good eye good eye it is uh
I always knew this but uh it is crazy
that the dry
this thing you you probably think almost
nothing about takes a 30 amp in the
United States 30 amp at 240 volt hookup
that's like 7 kilow of
power what the heck that powers the
server rack your dryer is doing that
that's crazy I know it's not like 247
like just constant draw of that power
but
dang that's wild also yes if you are uh
C curious this is the appropriate fridge
to server ratio in your home all right
that's all for now um I have spent some
time poking around that ubiquity website
and honestly I could get myself into a
lot of trouble one of the other
interesting Concepts that I've been
wondering is getting back to I love my I
love me some mesh Wi-Fi and I think one
of the coolest things would be like uh
like establishing mesh Wi-Fi units
around the property but solar power them
so so using solar power I think you can
get enough you probably just need like
one panel probably I I don't actually
know um but that would be cool if
possible to establish like solar power
stations that then power um something
like mesh Wi-Fi and then probably since
you're doing it and providing like a
little power station somewhere um do
something like cameras or something like
that like game cameras or trail cameras
um I think that would be really cool
then you could do stuff like heat maps
of like Wildlife on the property that
kind of stuff I think that' be pretty
cool so so anyway um but also pretty
expensive and I'm not sure you can get
quite enough power like nowadays A lot
of these cameras they don't really take
that much power and then like a a mesh
Wi-Fi unit shouldn't take that much
power but anyway so that'd be kind of
cool U but then also there's a whole lot
of server stuff on the ubiquity website
also I will say one more time ubiquity
did not sponsor they didn't even speak
to me so all this is very unbiased uh
you get the unbiased truthful review of
those ubiquity units at least for now
those things are awesome so anyway
that's all for now uh check out the
neural networks from scratchbook at NN
fs. otherwise I will see you guys in
another
video